hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica I've
still got my Christmas hat even though
there hasn't been a Christmas update to
this game I'm still wearing it but in
this update there has been a new update
now in this video there's a new update
that you all should be aware of the
precursor update is now in the game so
when you guys were telling me there was
a huge alien temple or something or
other on an island it's now there
because that was in the developer early
access build of the game and I'm playing
the release build of the game which is
not bad
that thing that that is so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go back to my base
and then I'm gonna put names on the
locker because it got them over here and
then I'm gonna talk to you guys about
that thing that we're talking about over
here with the thing and the thing in the
thing I don't know why I did the intro
here but everybody ignore me I'm gonna
get back to my base real quick alright
hi Karen okay so now the precursor
update is in the game and apparently
that brings along with it not only new
alien technology but the necessary
components to be able to eventually not
in this update but kind of like laying
the groundwork for the rescue ship to
come get us out of this hellhole and
take us the [ __ ] home don't you [ __ ]
don't you [ __ ] dare oh don't you
[ __ ] dare it's okay yeah [ __ ] you and
also we have the recipe to be able to
build us a prawn and that means that
we're gonna be able to blue we're gonna
be able to dig up all these big deposits
of that thing and that thing whatever
the hell those are crunch that and meat
blast that basically we're gonna be able
to have all of the necessary materials
that we could possibly want we'll never
be wanting for anything ever again and
we'll be totally happy in all of our
life okay so we get the names on the
lockers first one goes out to Sarah
Johnston one who said hey mark make sure
you don't make your base too big the
larger they are the more likely the
wildlife is to attack it apparently now
I've never been able to actually make a
base underwater big enough to ever
experience this but I'm gonna try that
in a future episode I'm definitely gonna
try to make the biggest base that I
possibly can because I want to see what
is going to attack it next goes up to
Houma it's a Russian name that I can't
pronounce but I only see Poma there who
said mark have you ever thought about
playing subnautica and VR it's supported
in the game please make a VR special
episode now
in my recording room which is basically
just a converted bedroom I do not have
any VR stuff here but in the office I
actually do so I may be able to at some
point experience the horror that is the
ocean in full virtual reality which I
think will be more terrifying than any
other horror game I've ever played on
the VR you stout eight says key rules
for subnautica rule number one don't
forget about breathing rule number two
don't forget about breathing and rule
number three don't ever ever ever forget
about any of the Leviathans whether they
be Dragon Emperor or Reaper now I don't
think the emperor Leviathan is in the
game just yet or at least not fully
implemented in the game but the dragon
definitely is but we're gonna get to
that eventually because we got stuff to
do
I have the ability to make a prawn but
I'm pretty sure that's in a deployable
thing now let me look up the recipe for
that it needs aluminum oxide plasteel
aerogel and lubricant and I don't know
how to make aerogel spore sack and
aluminum oxide okay I can do that I know
where to get spore sacks anyway but
that's not important because right now I
want to show you guys the new thing and
I'm pretty sure it's on this other
island the second island that's actually
not an island it's just a mountain
underwater that has grown too big for
its britches so we're gonna go over
there first and I'm gonna take a look at
all this precursor [ __ ] because
apparently it's pretty intense and
apparently oh hey
apparently it's a pretty ridiculous and
it has something to do with how the
aurora got shot down I mean if I'm not
mistaken by the the screenshots that
I've seen it's literally a gun it's not
a temple it's literally like a gun
straight out of halo that's what it
looks like in and I'm not a hundred
percent sure about this because I've
never seen it with my own two eyes and
you guys gonna witness it with me
for the first time with our own two eyes
our collective 2.4 million eyeballs give
or take a few here and there are gonna
witness this for the first time and I
don't know what's gonna happen after
that
but I think it's gonna be amazing maybe
also I'm still recovering just a little
bit from being sick but I'm almost on 2%
better okay oh hi
that is a gun is that a gun that is 100%
a gun this like straight up a gun okay
well now we know it's shot down the
[ __ ] Aurora holy [ __ ] okay let me
take a look at the underwater portion
before I actually go up to the upper
portions oh my god that's amazing I mean
this is legitimately alien technology
here what kind of alien species put a
gun in the middle of the goddamn ocean
this is legitimately a gun I mean it's
some sort of installation but like I'm
not mistaken here this looks like
straight out of Halo what is this hello
these anchoring points are these power
substations or something like that oh
that's so cool and kind of creepy and
scary why is this just here why is it
anchored into the very bedrock I I have
no idea why are these floating I have so
many questions and I can only assume
they're gonna be answered by going
inside of this thing if I can go and set
in this thing I better be able to go
inside of this thing they better not put
a big old alien building and no way to
actually go inside it oh is that it yeah
sorry sorry fishies sorry sorry hello
reinforced dive suit fragment that
sounds good
can I have that is that gonna make me
have less damage from [ __ ]
oh no purple purple artifact Zed it any
way related to the purple guy algae
growth on the exterior of this device
indicated it has lain here for hundreds
of years undisturbed despite its age its
power source appears to be functional it
may prove to be compatible with in other
nearby technologies what awesome oh
there's a purple sign with my human
brain I can determine I need to get the
purple artifact and put it in the purple
thing I'm the purple guy this device
appears to be alien in origin and is
connected to up to a nearby forcefield
the technology is far beyond anything
encountered before the federation
nonetheless it appears to be functioning
like a normal lock it only needs the
correct kind of
key okay that makes sense so I just have
to find the rest of the purple fragments
to be able to unlock the lock and go
inside the gun so there's got to be a
way to do it because they not only gave
me one of them they also gave me a
keyhole is that in my recipe book do I
know how to do this
ion crystal and two diamonds I don't
even know how to make a [ __ ] ion
crystal I'm gonna be able to do that
alright so I got some splint to do I
need to find diamonds which I know I can
find on this island but before I do that
I'm gonna pop over to the other side of
the island here okay popping a squat
over on the other side here there
another forcefield
no jump doodle daddle over here no no no
not at all just camping out on there is
there one - yeah there is okay hello oh
hello everybody my name is markiplier
can i scan you hello markiplier here
mind if I scan you oh come on now don't
be shy okay
well oh oh cool I didn't even need to
build the thing I just got a purple
artifact well good thing I looked
instead of actually trying to do work
with my life okay so alright here we go
who are burski yay did I do hit have hot
turn it huzzah I did it I think scans
indicate the structure is composed of
metal alloy with unprecedented integrity
no match is found in the database
performing structural analysis okay well
this is bizarre this is like the biggest
mood shift in the entirety subnautica
that I've ever seen this is literally an
alien establishment built here hundreds
of years ago and as far as we know it's
completely abandoned but the technology
is still even though it's ancient far
beyond anything we're capable of and now
I'm getting flashbacks to like quake
anybody remember the first levels of
quake kind of looks like this whoa a
green terminal
I wonder what I'm supposed to be able to
do here identify the background message
being broadcast throughout the facility
partial translation available message
reads warning unidentified craft in
orbit of this planet will be destroyed
Fah prevent the rock loud get Thailand
in fast Uddin okay so these are German
aliens is that what I'm supposed to
believe are they Viking aliens unknown
language attempting translation I don't
know how are you gonna be able to do
that with no reference data you wouldn't
be able to actually like translate
anything all right this this terminal
was discovered within the alien facility
that was shot down the that shot down
the Aurora on Planet four five four six
be on approach it began to resonate
producing a low-frequency radio wave
containing complex but recognizable data
patterns matches no known technology
constructed from the same offer of
material as the facility itself seems to
be a solid-state computer of some kind
no recognizable user interface it is
like hey it is likely the alien species
which designed this technology evolved
or genetically selected sensory
apparatus to hear and understand the
information being broadcast by the
device and to communicate back the
mental processing power required to form
the con telepathy would imply the
designers are considerably more
psychologically developed than the
common human using the evidence gathered
from this device it may be possible to
extract comprehensible data from other
such devices should they exist
assessment further alien data required
now this is fascinating this is
literally us discovering an alien
species and I don't know if the in the
universe of subnautica we've ever
discovered an alien species analysis of
the patterns on the walls cannot be
ascertained whether their purpose is
aesthetic or functional further data
required let's just assume that they
planned every minut detail of this
entire facility and that every intricate
pattern on the walls serve a function
your best probability of disabling this
facility is achieved by accessing the
control room in the lower section how do
you know there's a control room in the
lower section I mean thank you for the
clue and all that oh no
I'm gonna pick this up it's an ion
crystal let me scan it and then grab it
with my bare hands little boy all right
God one oh it's a Minecraft doodad the
hell does that do can I get some
information on the ion crystal these
alien cubes each store the equivalent
energy of a small nuclear detonation why
am i holding this why would I be holding
this someone take this from me I need an
adult the alien technology is able to
keep the stored atoms in a permanently
stable state however under the right
conditions the reaction could be wreak
adelies and the energy released in a
controlled manner they were used like
batteries storing power generated at the
main reactor and then transported
wherever they were needed assessment
possible source of escape velocity
energy whoo I'm on board with that
considering the Aurora's like engines
exploded because then further down but
this is still like absolutely
fascinating this is a monumental
occasion but why did they put this here
to automatically destroy any ship that
came into orbit of this planet like it
just automatically did it it's guarding
something here something more is here
like there is obviously more to this
than meets the eye because not only
would there be aliens here but there
they put this gun here for a reason and
if it's not guarding something then what
is it trying to do is it trying to keep
people out is it trying to stop people
from going further is it trying to
protect what's left is it trying to
selectively filter out the unworthy like
what is the reasoning here I guess we'll
find out unknown language attempting
translation yep do that alien weapon
schematic can I kill a Leviathan now
this data set appears to be
multi-dimensional schematic for some
kind by mapping the by mapping the
pattern to three-dimensional space it is
possible to gather the basic
understanding of the superweapons
internal workings which may help
identify a way to disable it
construction material the facilities
unknown construction materials
identified as an ultra hard nonreactive
metal
algum synthesized from offworld
materials there's no indication that it
can be damaged or destroyed by known
means power the schematic indicates the
weapon was to be powered by a separate
self sustaining power plant located
elsewhere on the planet the location is
not listed but there's evidence the
designers intended to harness the
planets natural thermal energy the
facility consist of the upper
engineering section where the schematic
was found in the control room which is
accessed via the security sealed
elevator shaft or a separate underwater
moon pool does it moon pool in here is
there
uh-uh the control room in the lower
section houses the only known way to
interface with the weapon however the
schematic does not detail the operation
procedure or installed security misses
so obviously these aliens don't want
people fiddling with their giant gun I
mean if I had a giant gun on some random
planet
I wouldn't Swan some offworlders
fiddling with it and destroying it I put
a lot of work uh hello okay this is
gentle I've got a tingling down in my
southern reasons retreat my my southern
reasoning regions okay hello oh yeah
hello I don't have any more artifacts
left do I need to go build another
artifact before I'm able to actually go
deeper because I can do that I just need
to make two diamonds because I have two
ion crystals so that means I should be
able to make more artifacts so long as I
get enough diamonds okay I'm gonna do
that ah oh oh it's day how lovely
okay so I'm gonna hunt down some diamond
but I've also discovered that in these
caves inside this mountain there's
actually more like there's more alien
construction in here I don't know if
it's only for lighting or if they kind
of devise some kind of power array
that's strewn throughout this mountain I
I can only see her eyes at this point
and I'm only getting gold
where's the goddamn diamond there it is
I need four whew I found the cave of
lithium apparently Oh what is that hello
I found something okay good good yes
what what is this is he - can't where Oh
insert fuel crystal
okay I thought I needed one of those
what is that what did I find
is it a portal do I walk through it oh
boy here we go
this structure is currently powered down
in AD attendeth its intended purpose is
unclear possible theories ceremony or
religious role industrial applications
advanced transportation network may be
prudent to search the area for further
examples of alien architecture and
technology
well I've powered it so you know that's
a thing should I just waltz in there
without any care thought about my own
safety
just with reckless abandon ponder
forward and here we go okay I'm doing it
ha my brain my brain
am i okay this is all right where am I
now
Oh who what well am I in the same place
I was Brehme it kind of seems like the
same island but maybe it's not Oh am I
on the other Island
what I am I'm on the other Island
why that's nuts holy [ __ ] we got an
instant transportation between the both
islands oh my god that's awesome well
that's awfully convenient now I can be
able to go wherever I want I can build
do bases but I don't need to be over
here right now that's awfully convenient
well hell yeah well I mean good did I
take fall damage did they finally
implement fall damage those sacks of
[ __ ] god dammit alright anyway I found
another purple artifact so we're good to
go on that front alright so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna go back into the
building and I'm gonna use this other
purple artifact if this doesn't give me
all the way down to the bottom I'm gonna
have to cut the episode there but I want
to see what's inside this structure and
now that I have a key I don't have to
cut the episode there and I can actually
keep going down ah ah do not fall and
die do not fall and die that is bad
that is very bad to fall and die and
hopefully maybe there's some sort of
alien medbay where they're gonna heal me
up with some
alien babes one can dream warhorse Shoop
deep up D ready to get my grundle
tickled here we go
III I mean it's pretty interesting that
I'm just so bravely venturing into this
thing I mean I don't know why but I am
okay here we go try this one hih booth
hey boo ski I don't know why these are
completely unusable after I put them in
oh cool oh it is a moon pool
illegitimately is a moon pool whoa
should I bathe in this oh my god is that
is that door open now can i dock my
Cyclops in here I'm just gonna go out
and I'm gonna find out where this is so
that I can like it oh that's darkens
Giri okay
all right Zoe yeah ah I mean the water
alone I hate that oh okay so I'm
assuming that the door opened once I put
the key in there and that's gonna be
good because that allows me to get any
or more readily instead of taking the
long walking route but this is just
fascinating what kind of ships what kind
of alien underwater vessels did they
have that helped us or help them explore
the underwater debits here cuz there's a
lot to explore I hold these [ __ ] and and
possibly if I get enough of these chunks
I should be able to power my base like
indefinitely right that should be an
option I'll go up there in just a second
I'm gonna see what's over here first
it's easy to get low oh my god it's
another teleporter where does this one
go
is it even active I want to go where
does it go all I want to know do you do
something hello my name is markiplier
please open for me
do you know who I am do you know how
many subscribers I have a lot hydration
detected I better not dehydrate while
I'm down here because I might be very
pissed I'm gonna be very pissed oh is
that another key so there's a key
thank you well thank you very much well
that's awfully helpful if I do if I'd
known there's so many keys lying around
I would never even have to have made one
I didn't make one so I don't know why
I'm complaining but I got one this is
gonna be able to explore a little
further oh my god scan indicate the
weapons control room weapon control and
lies beyond the doorway so I'll be able
to control the weapon or at least turn
off I don't think I don't think anyone
should have that kind of power
it's my planet now no rescue ship shall
come for me I don't need the comfort of
humans I've got to come for the fish
rights oh god that got that got that
hello can I break you oh it's that easy
huh pabu ski boink oh my hand oh [ __ ]
don't probe me please
ah don't oh god ow oh oh Chism's
warning infected individuals may not
disable the weapon this planet is under
quarantine
infected infected with what there's
gonna be some kind of like the curse of
flesh of available alien data indicate
the presence of a second facility
elsewhere on the planet evidence
suggests it is located 800 meters below
sea level approximately one kilometer
southwest of this installation
information recorded to databank
oh there's another facility there is
legitimately another facility here in
this vicinity and if it's under 800
meters that can only mean that it is in
the inactive lava zone where the dragon
Leviathan is and that's bad that's very
bad because I don't know if I want to
fight the dragon Leviathan but for some
reason we've discovered the humans I I
don't think this is a thing where I'm
infected like I got it when I'm here no
I think this means that humans in
general are infected with something that
this alien race considers to be a
disease and that may be like the curse
of life or something like that but it's
something deeper here and this mystery
is fascinating so anyway that is all the
time that I have for this episode but
this is just intriguing I have no idea
how deep this goes but I have a roadmap
for what I'm gonna be able to do in the
next few episodes I'm going to number
one build the prawn suit number to build
the Cyclops number three build a better
base in a better launching pad for me to
go and explore deeper and darker in the
depths of subnautica but this is
fascinating I have no idea what we're
gonna find in the other alien facility
oh my god it is dark ah ah why did I
park my C Mon so far away but anyway
I've got a plan for the next few
episodes but I don't know where this
road is going to lead and I am so happy
that I started back up when I did
because this is the perfect time to
explore the mystery of the actual story
let me know what you guys think down the
comments below what does this all mean
where is this going to go
who is this alien race is it some sort
of robotic race that doesn't like
organic life is it something where
there's a race that thinks they're so
superior that genetic inferiority is
treated as a disease I don't know but I
want to hear your thoughts so let me
know down the comments below and thank
you everybody so much for watching and
as always I will see you in the next
video
but I
[Music]